Alright, so first off,
I just wanna say
this is the wildest stuff ever.
Only in 2024,
where you gonna have a guy
that's actively participating in piracy
filming himself on a TikTok and posting it online.
Second thing that is wild is
this guy looks remarkably like this guy right here.
Now, people say this guy is a Yemeni pirate.
I can't confirm that.
I don't know where he's from,
I don't like
have his birth certificate or any of that stuff.
But one thing is for sure,
she looks exactly like Timothee Chalamet.
Why? Do you know this guy from Dune?
From the new
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory movie?
Look, all I'm saying is
if somebody from Hollywood wanted to go, like,
rescue this dude and bring him out of there and like,
take him to America,
he had a real.
He would have a real chance at being like
at least a stunt double for this guy.